the Mexican fisherman story are you
familiar with that I don't think I am an
American businessman goes on holiday to
Mexico he gets taken out fishing by a
local Mexican and he asks the Mexican
how he spends his time the Mexican says
I fish a little on the morning I catch
enough for my family we go back we cook
we laugh around the fire and I spend
time with my children and the American
businessman goes that's stupid here's a
better idea what you should do is
actually spend most of your day fishing
and then with the Surplus fish you could
sell them at the market Mexican
fisherman says why would I do that once
you've got the additional money you
could start to employ some of your
friends and they could come out fishing
with you too and you could catch more
fish which you could sell at the market
for more money why would I do that you
would be able to incorporate in America
and you would maybe be able to start a
canning Factory so that you could own
the entire production process and you
could then sell the company for a lot of
money and why would I do that he said
because you'd be able to fish a little
on a morning and then go back and spend
time with your children around the fire
very good and I often think about that
as a much more direct route to happiness
the place you end up is the place you
started from